abone ol
[Müzik]
çok seviyorum olsun Tamam canım benim
ben haklıyım İlkokulu olsun Gözünüz
çıktığınız zaman yapıyorum ancak bu
canım İyiyim iyiyim mavi oluo Yok yok
oldu Çok güzel sonra ama benim sen bir
tane korkma
ben seni de onu diyorum olmuyor Benim
sesim aramızdaki sana dedim ya
abone ol
Ben buradan plastik geldin oğlum sağlık
internet buradan tut nasıl Madrid gün
yapıyorum Bakalım internetten 84-85
dünyaya yeni gelen ve benim aslında çok
çalıştırmak
zty Sağlık olsun kaldırıp indirmek için
bir bakalım yaparken hiç bir tarafta da
ben atayım daha kırdın aslında niye
öğretmen işte uykum geldi abi ama bu
sorunun yanlış olsun insan Allah uzun
bıraktım
ya Sen iyimisin abla Ama bacağım Yani
ben söylüyorum o Sembol Ama bu oldum
nasıl olabilirim seviyorum var mı o
gelmedim bakmıyor
Ne oldu gözlerim oldum bu numara al bunu
tanem çok beğendim bakalım Tamam var mı
o çok kız
Sağ ol Osman asla daha küp iPhone daha
kötülerini dünyanın Gelince gideriz ok
yanıp ben de gelmem kızım aynı anda da o
yapalım mı o Palette yoğun bakımda oldu
[Müzik]
anlatacağım insanım öğrendim
2000'li kulaklık kendim söyleyeceğim çok
güzel Kim kim buradan kalbim ama çok iyi
insan bana ama insanlar olacak ya bir
şey olur bilmiyorum Ne zaman geleceksin
Annem Neredesin olabiliyor Kanka
videoları ilgili tedavisi bir şey var
mıydı
o zaten yapacaksınız oğlum Oğlum biraz
daha da aslında bir çok insan öldüren
internette bulacak mı acaba sana
söyleyeyim Bu başlangıçta de çok güzel
oldu
o gitmişti camın önüne gittim Sen bana
anneye onu kullanıyorum zaten Öyle olsun
zaten yem nasıl çekebilirim oldu bu
telefonu 20 alırım yarın yok yarın yok
bir at diyecektim şimdi bakalım bak yap
Türk'ün gördüm olsun canım
ve sac sanal gerçeklik gözlüğü döneceğim
yarın izinli oluyorsun değil mi Yani bu
ulaşabilirsiniz artık nasıl tarafında
[Müzik]
Canım işim yapabilirim ama seni
istemiyorum Ben sana gitsin dedim
bu durumlarda al birden artık
koyabilirim şu an konuşmadan olacak mı O
ne gittim basit görüntüyü 1999-2006
canım durdurulurmu
çok güzel bir herkesin diyorum
ilk 4 ayında çekilmiş bir video
arkadaşımız o kafasına taktığı
ve enstrüman ama o dur onu kontrol
ediyor
abone ol
o siyah al Sana yaklaştım gerçeğim seni
zaten sağlık ne demek istiyorsun Ne da
yakın olduklarını gördüm ben istedim
gerçek Tamam mı canım oğlum İyi ki
Çok teşekkür ederim sağ olsun yani
[Alkış]